[Music]
speaking up kids it's official now
tennis superstar Serena Williams is
gonna be a mama
she said social media on fire yesterday
with a snapchat suggesting that she is
20 weeks pregnant and that means that
she was playing in winning tennis titles
with a baby on board does this count is
baby's first championship the tennis
legend was already 8 weeks long when she
won the title Down Under Serena Williams
is expecting a little baby yeah although
I must admit I was a little disappointed
to find out she was pregnant when she
won the Australian Open which is not
cool because technically that's a
doubles match cheating I'm just gonna
put it out there
Serena teased the internet yesterday
morning with the snapchat caption 20
weeks only to delete it hours later
finally her rep confirmed the happy news
so just who is the guy who won game set
and match with Serena's heart here are
three things you need to know about her
fiance Alexis Ohanian he co-founded
Internet giant reddit when he was just
22 he's now the executive chairman of
the site one of the most visited in the
US the 33 year old entrepreneur is worth
an estimated nine million dollars he and
Serena met while having lunch in Rome
they dated secretly for 15 months before
getting engaged in December after he
proposed at the same table where they
met no word yet on whether the baby is a
boy or a girl
[Music]
you